we've been told before that Hollywood
respects male female creative
partnerships and from a few people that
we've talked to they always say you know
some of their tips are don't make one
person and disciplinarian of the group
but what would you recommend to people
on terms of choosing a creative
partnership I'm not so sure that I think
of what Roger and I do as a partnership
I'm not sure I mean I suppose people
from the outside would look at it and
say that it is but I think Rogers so
tsui generous and what he does he's like
you know hundreds and hundreds of films
and I kind of one at a time and and so
on and we mostly don't work on the same
projects but in terms of what we do in
business you know we own the business
together there is a distribution company
there you know there are common things
that we need to decide about an approach
having to do with how much of our money
are we going to spend on a film and you
know what entity will it come from so on
or discussion back and forth about what
do you think about this actor or what do
you think about that director or can you
recommend someone who'd work for you or
you know we really need to key grip what
it this kind of thing goes on on a daily
basis um I don't think we've ever had a
serious disagreement about anything to
do with whatever we do in business
together even a boxcar Bertha we both
agreed it would not change to be about
big bill Shelley so I don't I don't
really know how to answer you about what
can someone do because it just it works
okay all of that works okay if anything
there is a kind of question of you know
one wishing the other would take more
charge of legal and accounting because
neither of us really wants to do that so
I don't know I just don't remember
having a serious disagreement about any
to do with business but I also know that
in our marriage whether they say one of
the big test is if you build a house and
we built two houses and I think what
actually happened which maybe is what
happens on the business end of this is
that we each had a couple of specific
things that were very important to us to
have in the house the location of the
dining room and the location of the
bedroom the size of the living room and
we both wanted the opposite thing and we
just trade it and I got the dining room
where I wanted it and he got the big
living room and that was the end of it
and we never really had a discussion
about it again and the same thing
happened with the second house so I
think maybe that kind of thing is
happening on a regular basis with us in
business which is kind of thinking about
what's important to the other person
then letting it go and making a stand
and having that be hurt
you